hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from the 1971 Moscow
tournament it's basically the alien
Memorial Tournament the 15th edition of
alien Memorial Tournament it's Anatoly
Karpov versus of last female court and
it's one of the strongest tournaments
held at at that point 18 of the
strongest grandmasters - some of them
like we didn't have Bobby Fischer there
even though he was at the peak of his
power it's 1971 but he's busy playing
the the candidate tournaments so here
everyone is your Boris Spassky is here
tile is here
Hortis here Anatoly Karpov is here
Tigran Petrosian is here was Miss Love
is here so a lot of very strong players
and Karpov is uh well maybe not the
lowest rated but among the lowest rated
here he's about 20-25 60 euro rated and
he's 19 years old at a time maybe 20 so
yeah this is one of the games that I
started to show you while we're waiting
for the next big saga to begin while you
are all busy casting your votes and well
I believe tomorrow is the Tata Steel
India Edition so we're also going to be
covering that but that means said let's
check out the game and I do have some
very important announcements but we're
gonna save that for the end of the video
and it's regarding the other stream on
Saturday where we're gonna have a nicely
chess tournament and some some fun and
games so stay tuned now getting back to
the game Karpov with the white pieces
opened with e4 Hort replies with c5 we
have the Sicilian defense Knight to f3
d6 and now d4 sorry about that we have C
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 in
the knight to f6 we have knife to c3 and
now E six the metas happening a
variation of the Sicilian no idea if I
pronounced that correctly never actually
knew how do you pronounce that I always
thought it was happening and then I
heard it was a haven inga so could it
could be anything if any of you do have
a precise way to do it to do sure in the
comments below and here G for it was
very popular the time it's very popular
today the Charis attack against this hey
Meninga you want to expand all the way
to g5 putin
then continue with f4h for if if
possible we have night the c6 by Hort
and now g5 pushing the night back with
937 and now f4 we have a 6 by taking
away the b5 square from karpova's
night's bush of the e3 in carp of
continuous development and the Bishop to
e7 and here rook the g1 saying that
castling kingside
would be a bit too mature h4 h5 is
coming so not not a problem for Karpov
even though the engine will give you
that it's it's ok the castle here but
you know in those days in the pre engine
era no one was this grave so here court
finds a way how to trade off some of the
pieces and activate his pieces he goes a
night capture Sun before with Queen
captures on d4 end now 'if I've either
saying you mess up your pawn structure
or push go back with the Queen so Carter
was back Queen d2 we have pawn captures
an f4 Bishop captures and now Knight to
e5 getting this Knight into the game and
if Knight is captured then everything
just gets traded off which favors black
and if not you just have a very strong
knight on e5 so here Karpov goes and
also there's the there's the threat of
Knight f3 check just picking up the
Queen as it would fork fork the king and
queen so Bishop to e2 and now and also
this is move 14 and this position has
never been repeated again we should we
should just you know stated that Bishop
to e6 by horde and now Knight to d5
Karpov also grabs an excellent square
for his Night Court in eliminates it
immediately with the shop character
Sundy 5e captures and now Knight to g6
pushing the bishop back you cannot go to
g3 as you will lose the g5 pawn you have
to go to e3 to keep an eye on the pawn
here we have h6 challenging the the g5 1
and here Karpov is not afraid of Bishop
to age for check he he will gladly grab
this point car perfect picks up the pawn
with G characters and h6 Bishop to h4
check and now Karpov just goes back King
to d1
he will not be able to castle but he has
some ideas of playing c3 King c2 and
then Kathleen artificially we have G
captures on h6 Bishop captures on h6 o
Karpov is
upon for the moment and now Bishop back
to f6 attacking the beat upon here so
carp of defense at c3 now with ideas of
playing King to c2 and bringing the
other look into the game and here Bishop
to e5 Bishop to e5 attacking the h2 pawn
but the real threat is just Queen to h4
just with a double attack on the point
and and the bishop here so you could try
a lot of things here king c2 is an idea
if try Bishop to g5 it's also possible
if a Bishop to g5 yes you prevent Queen
to h4 but then the Queen moves but now
you've allowed the rook to have this
semi open H file and Karpov doesn't want
to allow his opponent any moves so here
you can try to pause the video and try
to find a really nice karpova move well
i paused to be a well you pause the
video but i will give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such a such a nice carp omean move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook to g4 so it's a wonderful roof
lifts prevents Queen to h4 and doesn't
move the bishop so the rook is still
stuck there on h8 no real prospect for
this rook at least for now and you can
always shift it over to the Queen side
to start an attack if black manages to
Castle queenside so it's a really a
wonderful move and the black should
definitely think twice before grabbing
the h2 pawn because here yes you grab
your pawn back but now White has all the
time in the world to get the King to
safety the rook into the game even if
you go back to if I've looped the f1 is
coming and now Queen to d7 you prepare
castling just kink the b1 is sufficient
and if queenside castle then you can
shift the rook over to the Queen side
and the material is equal but White has
a much better position since the king is
not all that safe here you cannot go
King be 8 because Bishop captures an a6
and the white already has some ideas of
Queen e3 maybe Queen can come to a7
black white is the one who has the
bishop pair so definitely a much better
position for white so here instead of
grabbing the pawn queen the f6 by Hort
and now h4 in grabbing more space on the
King side and also preventing the
Castle queenside because if it is just
Bishop g5 wins material for Karpov so
after age four we have Queen to f5 but
now another excellent move by Karpov
rook to be four again attacking the b7
pawn and preventing the defense of the
pond by castling because now Bishop g4
just wins the queen since the rook from
before still guards the g4 square so
Karpov says you are still not not
casting anywhere and if b5 preventing
preventing well just rock out person b7
then just a4 and you're busting open and
on the Queen side again white will just
be much better here so after rook before
just Bishop to f6
bye-bye Hart going after the h4 pawn and
now h5 this or h5 pushing the knight
back we have Knight to e7 and now that
the knight no longer controls the f4
square Karpov moves the Ruby back rook
the f4 attacking the Queen and if the
Queen moves well the bishop could fall
so the Queen has to keep an eye on the
bishop Queens the e5 and now rook back
to f3 again saying what do you want to
do I have Bishop to f4 plant which could
be which could be very exciting for
example if you Castle queenside I'm
gonna go bush up to f4 and now you have
well you could either trade here which
is not something which is not all that
great or you could go Queen captures on
h5 if you want to win your pawn back so
it's really really a tough tough
situation for example if Queen captures
on b5 you will just get Queen captures
Knight captures and when the knight
bishop goes back you don't want to trade
it of course now you have problems here
you cannot you cannot pick up the pawn
here because of c4 if c4 you eliminate
the defender of well not eliminate but
you move the defender of the bishop on
f6 so we just lose a piece and if you
don't want to allow c4 for example if
you go b5 then just h6 and now Karpov
has a monster passed pawn the the
resulting endgame would be winning for
Karpov so here after look to f3 now we
don't have castles even though it is a
possibility I guess here we have Knight
captures on d5 this is the move Hort
goes for and Karpov just goes rook to d3
now puts pressure on the night
here and if you move the night also the
d6 pawn will be pressured so here if you
move the knight then again just bishop
therefore puts a lot of pressure here
Queen to e4 now even Bishop Devery the
possibility you're gonna lose this point
you're going to lose this pawn and well
your looks are still doing nothing the
night is really poorly placed on e7 it
again carpet would just have a much much
better position so here after loop the
d3 we have rook captures on h6 by heart
it is the the strongest move and rook
captures on d5 attacking the Queen we
have Queen to f4 and now Karpov has to
decide what to do does he capture the
rook on h6 does he capture the pawn on
d6 so all of these are very interesting
ideas for example if rope captures
you're gonna lose the rook on d5 with
check now if you move the King you're
gonna suffer a few checks King checks
sorry Queenie for check you're gonna go
Bishop b3 check here b3 and now black
well well of course go here to defend
the bishop the but also now you've
created a lot of holes here around the
White King and it's hard to say if white
will be able to push this pushes
advantage all the way to a win because
the the White King will also be under
attack at it at some point
so after this Queen t4 move Karpov
doesn't like rook Queen captures rook
what about rook captures on d6 it's it
almost it's almost a good move but here
Hort prepared the bishop captures and c3
a very sneaky idea where you don't
really have a lot of good options for
example you could go be captures on c3
but then you just go look out for sandy
sex Queen captures and the Ruby d8 trap
score puffs Queen so here a Karpov just
loses so after Bishop captures on c3 you
would have to go for Queen captures on
h6 here you would be you would be upper
look as white but it doesn't matter
Bishop to e5 and white is just in a very
bad situation I were threatening to pick
up the rook and again when the Queen
with rook the eight so after the rook
moves back
now you go rook the c8 and here even
though you're down the rook Queen to h1
is enough to compensate for the rook
there is just no good way of defending
against Queen to h1 it would just be it
would just be
terrible in the rook controls the entire
C file here so you could try there
should be three but still Queen h1 check
King II - you're gonna go Queen G -
check you know if you go back why black
just repeats and if you try to go
forward
Queen g3 check now you have to go back
because if you go forward now now you
get made it queen g4 check let's say
King captures here rook c5 check you're
gonna go King to f6 and now of course
Queen to d4 will be made since the pawn
covers the g6 and the e6 pawn so Queen
captures rook not not all that great
rook captures pawn allows the sneaky
Bishop captures on c3 rook sacrifice
so here Karpov just goes back Luke to d3
and now he also allows his King to
finally reach the c2 square because the
rope blocks the Queen's attacked at a c2
square and is preparing to bring the
other look into the game so here we have
Queen the h1 check where if you trade
Queens ok if you block with the Queen
this is just not all that great
King g7 the rook is coming into the game
and black has a very very very nice game
even though White has the best h1 but
with its bishops of opposite colors it's
hard hard to imagine you will be able to
do anything about that so after King
Queen - h1 check you cannot block with
the bishop otherwise you lose a piece
King the c2 this this becomes possible
because the rook on h6 is still
undefended so you have to capture the
look if you don't capture the rook just
Queen captures rook and you are down the
rook so here a hoard captures the rook
we have Queen captures on h6 by Karpov
and now Bishop to e5 the bishop is under
attack and you also have to keep an eye
on the h8 square with the bishop so so
to not allow Queen h8 checked and the
winning of the rook on a king e7 does
seem to prevent both ideas but then rook
f3 is just super strong again there's
the threat you cannot defend it after
Bishop e5 you're gonna go Queen g5 check
and now everything just went to the
regardless of what black places if f6
you just win the seventh rank checked
King here Queen captures here and now
all of the squares around the black king
or covered row covers a5 Bishop c4 is
coming you're just dead loss here so
here
Queen to h6 we have Bishop to e5 still
keeping an eye on this h8 square but
Karpov just played Queen to g5 and well
it was in this position that was
steaming hot decided to resign the game
because there's just not all that much
he can do I he can't really move the
King anywhere if you try something like
King to d7 to get the gate you cannot
castle of course the Queen is covering
the d8 square
you cannot go King to d7 because just
Queen captures here the the D pawn will
be pinned so here you don't really have
a good move it's just a terrible
position for black and also Karl you
know just as a bonus Karpov has a past H
bone that's ready to be pushed so
there's also that and here you don't
really you don't really have anything to
go to go on also the thread is Queen to
g8 check just picking up the rook so not
a lot of moves here if King H if you can
get afraid you just continue pushing the
past pawn and it's just pointless to
continue playing this will black Bishop
to f3 also is a possibility you're gonna
go after this pawn also you can just put
it here to guard the h7 point then go
Queen to g8 it's just whatever black
plays a losses so yeah after Queen to g5
a [ __ ] to resign the game and an
excellent victory for Anatoly Karpov
I maybe forgot to mention but Hort was
higher rated than Karpov here Hart was
around 2600 and something little and the
carpet was around 25 25 40 whereas Boris
Spassky who also played the tournament
was 2690 almost 2700 but here now I give
you the final standings of this
tournament which will well may come to
you as a surprise but also it may not
come to use a surprise here are the
final standings of the tournament as you
can see Anatoly Karpov won this
tournament with 11 out of 17 well it's a
tied tied first with Leon each 9 but
still a remarkable performance when you
consider who also participated there you
have it unlock or probably on each tine
vasily smyslov
then you have to come on off Petrosyan
mikhail tal with nine and a half out of
17th all tied with boris spassky in nine
and a half out of 17 Robert Barron was
Tim Horton David branch
Viktor Korchnoi just a lot of very
strong very strong grandmasters and as
you can see even though this is
basically the era where Boris Spassky is
the world champion and Fisheries
you know defeating all of the candidates
that the fight Spassky it is actually
Karpov who is who is dominating the
scene you know for example in India in
the memorial here just five wins 0
losses and 12 draws so ok a lot of
people have zero losses Stein has zero
losses miss love has zero losses and
took one of his zero losses but still an
impressive performance by Anatoly Karpov
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it also I wanted to show you a bit more
about Karpov in his younger days just he
was just just a monster so maybe maybe
some of you also will be interested in
in voting for Karpov in the inner poll
that will decide on the next big saga
which you will find in the description
below if you still haven't voted also
now the at the announcement I wanted to
make the stream for the for celebrating
the 500 thousand subscribers will happen
on Saturday and all of the the info will
be in the description below we will have
a two hour Lee chess tournament as we
usually do then we're gonna have some
games against subscribers I will be
joined by Yann Almighty and well some
other surprise guest so I do hope you
enjoy that as well now we're gonna have
picking of the winners of the Michael
Tao video where you all of you wrote
wrote some nice comments and wrote
hashtag tile as usual the rewards will
be 10/10 Amazon gift cards and 9.9 of
them will be valid at $25 and the main
one will be 250 dollars as a the
greatest Amazon price where you can you
know buy yourself a nice book or as
usual about the facial action figure so
that being said all the description all
of the info will be in the description
below and also a link to delete chess
tournament is already available so you
can already join it also will be the
second link in the description below the
first one will take you to a poll where
you can vote on the next big saga so
that's it with the announcement more
more information soon so I would like to
thank if not euro Freiburg
or chadwin and [ __ ] ingenious for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
soon
continuing to checking up on your
wonderful suggestions tomorrow we start
with the Tata Steel India edition and
well just whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day